but now welcome back to on sense of me
Rosanna local to the info peers just for
the next few days then he's back from
his holes and I know one story he's been
following very closely Trump
yet more trials more criminal procedures
more everything else and of course we
had that mug shot seen around the world
days since former president Donald Trump
was booked and charged inside an Atlanta
jail house this picture of him has
become a money spinner would you believe
it for his presidential campaign more
than seven million dollars has been
raised by his team that's what they're
saying anyway they're selling T-shirts
beer glasses bumper stickers dumbed with
a scaled face of the Don the Republican
front runner so who is the real mug here
the man packed by the police or the
scores of people who've paid for their
own piece of it well to discuss that I'm
joined by billionaire investor Kevin
O'Leary and by the founder and CEO of
the Investment Company Point bridge
Capital Hal Lambert also a major
Republican donor who switched his
support from Trump to Rhonda santis so
gentlemen thanks for making time for us
this evening Kevin I'll I'll start with
you I mean there really was no other way
Trump was going to spin this other than
the money raising opportunity right
well these are unprecedented times we've
never had a situation in a presidential
election where over 90 indictments have
been basically registered and the
trouble is probably if you're an
anti-trumper I mean you have to look at
it from both sides of the aisle it's the
fair way to review this situation
it's so noisy now that no one remembers
one indictment from another so if
another 100 indictment comes it's just
background noise
regarding how it's moving the needle
that's the problem for both sides it
isn't it doesn't seem to matter the
first election with Republican parties
come and gone everybody's still at one
percent except DeSantis he hasn't moved
the needle either and Trump Remains the
far ahead Forerunner and these these
indictments have not had any traction so
to actually monetize it looks like a
brilliant marketing move that that shot
that mug shot if you hate Trump you want
to wear it proudly if you love Trump you
want to wear it wear it proudly and
that's what they're doing and it it
appeals it seems on the merchandising
front to both sides and that's
remarkable it really is and so they're
doing a lot of fundraising at the five
to twenty dollar level online it's been
highly motivational for the Trump base
and it really boils down at the end of
the day to what happens in just a few
States as it always does in a
presidential election it'll be
Pennsylvania probably that decides by
less than a hundred thousand votes what
do those independent voters think that's
unknown
as you said both sides they are really
important to bear in mind uh on this
although in the UK we have a product
called Marmite which people say you love
to hate and I think when you're looking
at the the anti-trumpers as you called
them there they may even be a money
spinning opportunity here I mean look
there are some memes our producers have
prepared about this uh let's take a look
uh he got him as the Joker here uh in a
National Portrait Gallery or something
like that I mean you know this type of
stuff seems to fare well for him and
it's stuff that he's used to Hal talking
about the money side of it
um Trump is in need of quite a lot of
money I'm not talking about his personal
uh finances we've also obviously seen
bits of tax receipts and things over the
years but in terms of his legal fees
astonishing at this point
yeah I mean he it was reported he spent
over 40 million dollars just in the
first half of this year of some legal
experts I've spoken to estimate it's
going to cost him over 10 million
dollars a month going forward uh that's
a lot of money and so he's trying to you
know raise this small dollar money to
pay those legal costs so you've got
people making forty fifty thousand
dollars a year effectively subsidizing a
multi-billionaire's legal fees uh you
know it's their choice to do but uh you
know it's not being spent uh to get him
reelected I mean he's going to be
spending most of his money on on legal
fees and most of his time so I think
that's going to be a a real detriment to
him uh he gets all the the free media
that's that's helpful and that's what's
kept his poll numbers up but as far as
being able to campaign and being able to
actually get out and get in these states
he's gonna I mean Imagine One indictment
he's got four uh it's it's going to be a
lot of stress a lot of pressure a lot of
time with you know obviously requests
from legal on on Discovery and all those
kinds of things it's expensive if it's
time consuming and I I think it's a real
disservice quite frankly uh to the to
the Republican party and and to donors
uh for much of that money to have to be
used that way uh versus being uh
re-electing uh people into Congress or a
president and I'll put you you you
mentioned the four indictments there
Kevin mentioned the sort of scatter gun
Approach at the at the start when he was
talking to us do you think if it is this
sort of uh lawfare as people are saying
this strategy is going to succeed or
fail for the side that are trying to
stop him getting into the White House
hell
yeah I mean also foreign
with these indictments so so that's been
helpful will it last I mean we've got
another five months until the first uh
the first caucus there in Iowa and you
know the the Iowan caucus is very
different you've got to be there you've
got to be working the ground the same
thing with New Hampshire the same thing
with South Carolina so it's not a
national election so we're not to
Pennsylvania yet and by the way uh if we
look at polling you know The
Independents are not for Trump on this
so I don't even if we looked at
Pennsylvania right now I don't see Trump
winning that state that's the problem I
have with this whole thing is
independent you know over 53 percent of
the country thinks that Trump is guilty
so when you go into that with that
number um that assumes those people are
not going to vote for him that's that
seems like a losing hand going into the
election yeah and you know Kevin you
were mentioning the problem is Emerson
pulling out latest uh this is after
these Republican debates which of course
Trump didn't take participates Tucker
Carlson instead but he was down six
percentage points DeSantis up two
percent points but Trump's still way way
out ahead and Kevin what about this
point the Hal brings up you know people
are entitled to buy a beer mug or a
bumper sticking with Trump's face on it
but they're funding his legal fees and
they may not be millionaires themselves
is there an Ethics point in that
I think there's a lot of ethical issues
but that doesn't determine who becomes
president great politicians great
leaders great generals great preachers
great managers are storytellers and at
the end of the day go back to Napoleon
he used to sit around the campfire with
his men and tell stories and those
stories emulate it all around the Empire
over a few months today that happens in
a few seconds on social media nothing is
more painful to watch than a boring
politician Trump is not boring now you
may find it just outrageous that a
potential president has been indicted
multiple times but there are millions of
people who simply don't care and at the
end of the day it's one vote at a time
now if they did care these polls at this
point should have moved on the first set
of indictments we're past 91 charges
nobody seems to care there now you know
it may frustrate people that don't like
Trump and it must frustrate people to do
but at the end of the day as I started
talking about this it's totally
unprecedented what happens next nobody
knows I will remind everybody that you
cannot become the president and pardon
yourself for a state charge you can do
that federally so this idea that he's
going to win the presidency and then
pardon himself that's not going to work
some of these charges like George are
state-based however also unprecedented
would be throwing a president or a
former president or an acting president
into prison that's not good for the
American brand many people speculate
even if he doesn't win the presidency
they won't put him in prison because
what does that say about America so all
of these narratives are happening at the
same time all of them unprecedented and
at the center of it a masterful genius
Storyteller that sucks the oxygen out of
all of his competitors and people keep
saying don't worry that'll change not so
far well if he doesn't get uh put in
prison what does it say about the
American justice system I guess would be
the cancer argument to that but here you
point on the storytelling how just
finally before we wrap up um one of
these criminal trials now set for next
year early 2024 the day before super
Tuesday what kind of effect is that
going to have
yeah I think it's going to have a
negative effect and I mean we're going
to possibly see Witnesses turn against
President former president Trump uh
they've indicted a lot of people so
we'll see what happens there but you
know you talk about being a great
Storyteller you know uh what happened to
Napoleon in the end you know you brought
up Napoleon he didn't turn out too well
at the end but I will say that maybe the
country's ready for more than a
Storyteller I mean look at DeSantis he's
there in Florida he's working around the
hurricane that's coming in he's looking
more presidential he's not having to
fight indictments I think there's
there's possible candidates out there
like Governor DeSantis that can show
leadership between now and the first
caucuses uh and people may change their
votes because the majority of the
country does care uh maybe the majority
of the Republican primary voters don't
care right now but the majority of the
country does and we're trying to win a
general election uh not 50 of the
Republican vote so you're back in
DeSantis now Hal Uh Kevin Hal thank you
so much great talking to you both